in the long winters of Minnesota hockey
is a way of life
the colder the better we enjoy winter
here I love the Four Seasons and I love
winter as much as summer so for this
community to be able to come out here
and have a really neat event like this
where it's free to attend you know a
reasonably priced food inside so
families can come down here and enjoy
hockey the way nature intended
each winter the U.S pond hockey
championships bring out the Hardy to
chase a little black Puck around Lake
Nokomis the end of the day I mean look
at this this is
unlike anywhere you're gonna find in the
world to have a pond hockey event like
this and we're just honored and humbled
to be able to be caretakers is such a
great event but as the planet warms the
hockey season is shrinking climate
change is chipping away at Minnesota's
winter ice and when we look at the
climate model projections for the future
and it's not just Minnesota but it's
really the entire region that Trend
appears to continue and so we expect a
continued contraction of you know not
just our winter season but the
opportunity to recreate the way that we
used to during winter Minnesota has lost
an average of 10 to 14 days of late guys
over the past 50 years according to
State figures the shorter the winters
get the more work organizers have to do
to make sure there's ice to play on
there's the shoveling lots of it in snow
blowing and finally the Zamboni
smoothing the ice to a glass-like Sheen
that leaves nothing but Jersey clad
players between puck
and goal but they'll have to move the
ice while temperatures allow researchers
say by the end of this Century another
one-third of the outdoor skating season
will burn up due to global warming John
hendron Al Jazeera on Lake Nokomis in
Minneapolis